POINTS.
GAMEHE PAST.
>> DUMPED ON THE RIGHT WING
BOARDS.
THIS PUCK IS COLLECTED BY JORDA
SPENCE.A PIECE IN THE
BLACKHAWHE HAD.OF FIRST PERIOD .
AGAIN, GOOD PATIENTS.
THE KINGS DON'T MIND THAT.
THEY DON'T MIND IT..
>> THERE IS A HUGE SAVE.D ACROS.
CENTERING.
OVER THE BACK.
>> THAT IS NICE NOW, CLICK
TUESDAY NIGHT
AGAINST ANAHEIM.
THAT FACE-OFF
LEADING THE BLACKHAWKS INIS ONE
COMING UP FOR THE BLACKHAWKS.
KOPITAR, THE LEFT SIDE.
KEMPE LOOKING
PUCK OR
IS IT ONE OF THE THINGS WHERE H
SNIPS IN THE
POSSESSION OF LA.
>> NOT L TO HIS
NORMAL SITE IN THEN GETS IT DONE
. THEY
HAD A CHANCE.
TRIED TO BATTED TO THE MIDDLE
AND COULDN'T GET IT THROUGH.
THE PUCK HITS THE PROTECTIVE
NETTING IN THE PLAY IS WHISTLE
GAME OF THE SEASON. IN THE
OFFENSIVE ZONE.
THEYEY
TALKING ABOUT.
MAKE THE SAFE AND CONTROL IT AT
THE SAME TIME.
De.L
OF THE SEASON. iPAD TO
JUST LOOK AND SEE IF THERE'S AN
'TWEEN THE SKATE AND THE LINE.
HERE'S ANOTHER LOOKQUICK.
ATHANASIOU BUMPED IN AT THE LINE
.OF THE SEASON FOR
JONES.
DIRECTION.
>> WE KNOW THERE IS
LOOK AT THAT.
HE KICKSTART SAID.